è stato scientificamente provato quel
cromosoma xx insieme una vagina porti
anche da parte del gentil sesso
l'impossibilità di credere che una
persona possa non essere curiosa tu stai
tranquilla leggere apre il libro non so
che ho un mio figlio
tu stai leggendo inserito il titolo di
un libro a vostra scelta
io e letta tutta saettano bello sì ma
non mi dire niente
ed è proprio questa tra si fa scattare
tutta quanta la reazione a catena tu fai
capire che non dovrei sapere non ti
interessa e non ci credo realizzare un
attimo testardi e quindi solitamente ti
buttano una cosa di pop quarati goes una
finta che alla fine un po deludente non
mi diventato vi prego capito niente
ed è proprio quel che non c'è niente da
fare tu abbassa gli occhi e gli dai la
prova del fatto che non ti interessa ma
che punto stai quando quando lei gli
dice che non ce la fa più
non ha già baciato no oddio scusa fa il
pezzo prima giusto sì la maglia che poi
non sai cosa succede col suo amico a
questo punto attacca con cioè non per
dirti niente ma lui poi diventerà uno
stronzo cioè è vero che lei gli ha messo
le corna
ovvio no nel senso cioè l'avrei fatto
core e io però voglio dire la mamma di
lei aveva avuto il tumore gli erano
separati i genitori dei capi e l'ha pure
no mista raccontato una trama e non la
voglio sapere o vabbè mica ti ho detto
niente potevo dirti 2000 cose pero stati
giusto facendo convinto che poi quando
li uccidermi per troppo triste no io
volevo troppo piangere
quindi penso che non devo aggiungere
altro a parte che cavone tutt'uno
stressante tutti ucciderei
qui sotto questo profilo sono
psicopatico cioè proprio vede così
capito niente
un grazie a chiunque si sia iscritto
abbiamo solo un commento cioè so che
sembra subito ma lo fa piacere grazie
ecco vorrei dire i nomi ma il computer
spento quindi
magari farò un altro video con le varie
generazioni in tiwari